When life gives scientists lemons, they look
at those lemons and say, “how can we use
this to test general relativity?”
Hi everyone, Julian here for DNews. I know
we’ve been doing it for a while now, but
launching stuff into space is still pretty
tricky. You’ve got to get a giant rocket
on a launchpad without it exploding. You’ve
got to start it up without it exploding. You’ve
got to send it into space. Without it exploding.
But assuming the payload still stays intact,
sometimes the rocket puts it in the wrong
place. that’s what happened in August of
2014 with a Russian Soyuz-Fregat rocket carrying
two of the European Space Agency’s Galileo
satellites. The rocket worked flawlessly most
of the way up there, and then in the last
stage it pointed in the wrong direction and
shot them off at an orbit that made them useless
for their intended purpose. Ah, so close.
Of course we’re talking close by space standards.
Which is just another way of saying the orbits
were really far off. They were supposed to
be in circular orbits a constant 23,222 km
(14429 miles) away from the earth. Instead
they were set on elliptical orbits, twice
a day they were 2,000 km (1242 miles) too
high, and twice a day they were 10,000 km
(6213 miles) too low.
The Galileo program is going to be fine. The
plan is to launch 30 satellites to use them
for global positioning, and really 24 of them
are needed for the system to be fully operational,
while the remaining 6 are there for backup.
So two of them whizzing about in the wrong
place is a minor setback, rather than a dealbreaker.
But, heck, while they’re up there, we may
as well do something with them. They’ve
still got fully functioning atomic clocks
onboard, so what experiments could you do
with a spacecraft traveling in an elliptical
orbit around a massive object while carrying
a super-accurate clock?
If you said test time dilation, you must watch
this show a lot. Hi mom!
Yes as you’re probably aware, according
to Albert Einstein’s theory of general relativity,
near massive objects, time moves slower. GPS
satellites already have to constantly adjust
their atomic clocks back slightly because
of their distance from the Earth. And yes,
according to special relativity their speed
also means that their clocks should run a
little slower, but the overall effect is the
super accurate clocks in space are a little
fast on the order of microseconds.
The wayward Galileo satellites have had some
course corrections because they have thrusters
and a bit of hydrazine fuel. Now their orbits
change by 8,500 km (5,281 miles) twice a day
instead of 12,000, but that’s still a difference
greater than the radius of the Earth (6,371
km) and then some. So what that means is compared
to our atomic clocks down here, the misplaced
Galileo clocks with run a little faster, then
a lot faster, then a little faster, then a
lot faster as they gets closer and farther
away from this massive hunk. I mean the earth,
not me.
Using those differences, we’ll be able to
check Einstein’s math. Sure we did it once
before with an atomic clock in 1976 that hitched
a ride 10,000 km into space, but that experiment
only lasted a few hours. We can pull data
from these satellites for over a year and
be four times more accurate than before. We’ll
be able to test the math vs the measurements
to an accuracy of 0.004%. And we’ll be able
to do it thanks to a mistake that we turned
into a happy little accident.
And I’ve got more good news, everybody!
TestTube now has a newsletter!
Get a weekly round-up of our most popular
videos across all our shows at TestTube.com/fwd
So I glossed over how GPS satellites work,
and though I’d love to ramble all about
them, Trace’s clock was a little faster
than mine and he beat me to it. Check out
the amazing science behind knowing where on
Earth you are right here.
Have you
ever turned an almost fail into an epic win?
Sure you have, so let us know in the comments,
subscribe for more, and I’ll see you next
time on DNews.